this was the only kingdom in all of
africa where women had an equal voice
[Music]
we are set in an actual historical world
and yet some of our storytelling is
fictionalized braveheart was a template
absolutely for the films one of my
favorite movies historical fiction i
think is actually the best description
so many of the elements are true
um and that was the fun part to be
authentic to
everything from who these women were the
kingdom what was happening at that time
the production design everything
mirrored what it really was historically
what was going on at the time in terms
of the big battle between the two
kingdoms and what was going on
politically socially economically to do
that type of world building for a story
like this was fun our characters within
this real world were fictionalized yet
they reflected these real women what
they went through
i used the phrase intimately epic with
every department head and certainly when
i spoke with danny hernandez who's our
fight and stunt coordinator and also our
actors it started with the conversations
with them that the best action is story
driven and character driven and the best
way to do that is to have performance
within it so you guys are going to be
doing your own fighting and your own
stunts and it's one thing to say that
it's another to have actors embrace that
every single one of them wanted to do
everything and kept doing it until they
got it perfectly it took danny to create
a fighting style that an audience could
believe women legit beating men which is
what really happened um how do you
create that what does that look like a
lot of people working together but it
started with the desire of the actors to
do what i asked of them which was
you're doing it all it's breaking it
down into pieces when this character is
fighting what is it about giving each
vignette that we have a beginning middle
and end and that the knowledge of seeds
that we planted throughout the film that
leads us to this big epic battle that
some of those seeds are now paying off
in this so again that it is personal and
character driven and story driven that
it's not just random violence or random
fighting it was making it bite-sized so
that it didn't feel overwhelming and
shooting it
people do not even in this day and age
think of women as warriors as fighters
as having heart and courage these women
in the 1800s absolutely had that they
were the main fighting force of this
kingdom and they trained for it and they
wanted to be there they wanted to be
fighters they were athletes and there
was a beauty in their power
in how they trained in their athletic
bodies they were praised for it we see
what happens in this day and age and it
is getting better slowly but it's still
not to where it should be the more we
can put women up on screen to show that
we have an innate warrior to celebrate
their fitness and their athleticism and
their skill again these are not
stunt doubles doing that fighting this
is these actors these women viola davis
did that to somebody did that we can do
that these are not superheroes these
were real women i hope we can see yes
this is possible i can be that
this was the only kingdom in all of
africa where women had an equal voice on
the council for every man there was a
woman who had the equal power and voice
in the kingdom the fact that the woman
king was a real position we didn't make
up this cool name it really was called
the woman king and this woman was
elevated
to a position next to the king and
helped him guide the kingdom we're not
just putting these badass women on
screen but we're telling a bigger story
than that of who these women were what
the society was like but also in the
research i didn't realize how big dance
was to this culture as well so not only
did these women train to fight 24 7.
they also created these elaborate
choreographed dances that celebrated
themselves got them ready for war i
loved that i was able to bring that
element within this film as well
[Music]
the oyo battle absolutely it is an epic
battle i studied with the paulie morgan
our dp we studied braveheart gladiator
last of the mohicans it was absolutely
this thing that was looming at the end
of the schedule but i put it there one
to give the actors enough time to to
train
um for those sequences i needed our crew
to be the place where we were all so
comfortable with each other working at
another level before we got into that
because it was absolutely daunting and
we had 11 days to shoot it it was
intimidating um but everybody we just
had a plan and we stuck to that plan and
we got it done
[Music]